have you ever thought
when you're talking to your therapist
when you're talking to when you go on
that um rehab center like that yeah yeah
and we went away and we talked to people
was it easy for you to say I there's not
this is like is it was this your belief
there's nothing you can say right now
nothing will make me love myself I
cannot love myself I there's nothing I
can do I just don't feel like I I am
worthy of loving myself yeah have you
ever thought that all the time like I
mean yes well yeah that's what drove me
to that place to begin with I didn't
want to live yeah I didn't but but I
also didn't even understand really truly
understand what self-love was I didn't
understand what love was
I was 37 years old I really didn't
understand the concept of actual love I
understood whatever I thought love was
you know and I think we all have ideas
of what we think love is
and still it's a very amorphous you know
uh beautiful powerful amazing amazing
word term definition entity energy Love
Is Love Is Love is Like the highest
vibrational level of God like it's where
we I think we're all being pulled toward
where we're all supposed to be walking
but we can't love if we're still shaming
we can't love if we're still shaming if
we're still hating if we're still afraid
of each other because of all the
[__] that we've been programmed to
believe to be afraid of each other that
breeds that hate
you know what I mean it's it's so it's
so sad but again that's but guess what
you're not able to be programmed with
hate
if you've already filled yourself what
what real love is because you identify
the charlatans you know when people are
trying to just rile you up to be angry
with someone else for a thing that that
other person's afraid of
it it's insanity but so you become more
aware in all of that so to wrap all that
up then to come back to your question
about like my dad
10 years ago
if this was happening 10 years ago so
many different variables would be going
on my dad would have been living in
North Carolina at the time
um my mom would have been alive my mom
would have been alive my sisters would
uh one would have been married neither
of them would have would have had any
kids right
um uh it was 2020 to 2013. I would have
just had been finishing Chuck was not by
the way in a very good well I wasn't in
the worst pla I had a ways to go down
into the darkness from well all along
that time but were you ready for well
listen
I would have been I would have been okay
I mean I'm okay right now
I love my dad but my dad wasn't in my
life my whole life I mean really I saw
my dad two weeks a year and we would
talk on Sundays sometimes for like five
ten minutes my dad would call it
swapping howdies
and not that my dad wasn't there to give
me wisdoms along the way and love along
the way and encouragements and stuff and
I and I'm very appreciative why why was
it so intermittent well because my mom
and dad divorced when I was six and then
my mom remarried my stepdad and moved us
up to Seattle my dad's job was
relocating to North Carolina and my dad
was like well I guess I'll only see the
kids a little bit anyway and he [__]
off and went to North Carolina and he
worked for that company for another like
25 why did you forgive him or have you
obviously you have oh yeah well I think
that I forgave my dad I mean it's a
process you know like healing is a
process yeah it's not always like and I
forgave him then it's like I I am
forgiving I am healing it's a journey